you may have missed it but Special K
Special Counsel Robert Muller indicted
13 Russian nationals and three Russian
companies earlier this year the thought
all along was they would never show up
for court but now they're contesting and
it looks like this case is going to
court and that might be bad for Robert
molars investigation how and why no one
can so his question is more succinctly
than shows Jennifer who joins us now in
studio why would it be bad for this to
go to trial well because they're not
ready for it they indicted a case
prematurely against people that they
thought would never show up from Russia
and then one of the Russian companies
hired lawyers and sent them to court to
say we're here and we want to plead not
guilty and we want a lot of discovery on
your criminal case against us and mr.
Miller's people objected strenuously
they said we're not ready for an
arraignment but they're not here
properly and the federal judge said to
them mr. Muller you indicted this case
it's your case it's going to trial let's
have let's start this process right now
is December 8th he indicted people
without being ready to prove they were
guilty that is exactly right he abused
the grand jury process as he has from
the beginning of this outrageous
investigation authorized by mr. Rosen
Stein this is Rosen Stein's monster in
Spade you are a prosecutor a federal
prosecutor
it seems borderline immoral to indict
someone unless you can prove he's guilty
of the crime they did it for one reason
only Muller needed something Russian
like dressing on a salad to make his
investigation look good so he indicted
13 people and corporations in another
country that he thought would never show
up and bingo one of them shows up and
says prove it mother that's an
unbelievable story
imagine if he did that to Americans like
I don't know when he already has he's
done it to mr. Flynn that's unbelievable
judges gentlemen thank you for that
you're welcome thank you that's worse
even than I thought it was I appreciate
it